I was an avid science fiction reader
when I was a teenager and there's the
classic set of novels by Isaac Asimov
the foundation novels which are about
how a group of social scientists save
galactic civilization through their
understanding of the laws that determine
the behavior of societies and I wanted
to be one of those guys and the closest
you can get at this point I'm afraid is
being an economist dude do you still
believe that economists have that role
oh you know the in the novels these
people are able to predict with high
accuracy what's going to happen and find
the precise intervention that saved
civilization economics doesn't work that
good but but no it's there's a
tremendous amount of understanding that
comes from economic models and sometimes
that understanding can be can be the
salvation of the economy I believe that
we're living in one of those times right
now if we had only the level of economic
knowledge that the world had in 1929 I
believe we would have another Great
Depression the reason to believe that
that won't happen is that we think we
understand this thing at least somewhat
better than our grandfathers did
you